¡Paren las rotativas! Ha muerto SILVIO BERLUSCONI.
No hace falta que os diga quién es ¿Verdad?
Da igual desde dónde estéis viendo este
vídeo, TODOS sabéis de quién hablo. Y eso,
en sí mismo, es algo sorprendente...
Sin embargo, Berlusconi es una figura fascinante.
Muchos lo han querido comparar con DONALD
TRUMP pero... ¡Ya quisiera el pobre de Donald
Trump parecerse a Berlusconi!
Podríamos decir que Berlusconi empezó de
la nada y conquistó el poder absoluto como
casi nadie lo ha hecho en la historia. No
solo conquistó el poder político en Italia.
También aglutinó el poder empresarial…
y el mediático. Si el poder corrompe, el
poder absoluto corrompe absolutamente. Y la
vida de Berlusconi tiene muchas sombras…
¡Pero también muchas luces! De entrada,
hay algo que tenemos que reconocerle a este
hombre y que, francamente, es envidiable...
¡SU ENERGÍA! Pensadlo bien… Berlusconi
ha muerto este 12 de junio con 86 años: vamos,
que era un señor mayor. Pues bien, el año
pasado salió en TIKTOK con este vídeo.
No vamos a entrar en el mensaje del vídeo.
Lo que quiero resaltar es que ese señor que
veis tenía 85 años en el momento en el que
se grababa ese vídeo… en el que se estaba
presentando de nuevo a unas elecciones…
¡En las que tenía posibilidades reales de
ganar! No sé vosotros, pero… ojalá llegue
yo a los 85 años con esa energía.
Dicho esto, ¿Vamos a alabar a Berlusconi
en este vídeo? ¡Por supuesto que no!
Hablar de Berlusconi es hablar de corrupción,
leyes hechas a medida y un legado político,
cuanto menos, mediocre. Podríamos decir que
buena parte de los problemas de los que sufre
Italia - que no son pocos - son culpa suya.
Supongo que la mayoría de obituarios que
leáis por ahí también mencionarán los
muchísimos escándalos sexuales de Berlusconi
y sus bunga bunga parties… Nosotros vamos
a pasar por alto todo eso porque vamos a centrarnos
en dos cosas: el perfil político y empresarial
de este hombre.
Y, creedme, solo con eso tendríamos para
hacer una película. De hecho… ya hay un
biopic de Berlusconi y es toda una obra maestra:
LORO, de Paolo Sorrentino. Muy recomendable.
Para bien o para mal, Berlusconi ha definido
lo que es Italia hoy en día ¡Pero no solo
eso! También supuso una revolución en los
medios de comunicación de Europa. De hecho,
si ves este vídeo desde España y has nacido
en los años 80, tengo que decirte que Berlusconi
ha marcado tu infancia sin que te hayas dado
cuenta.
Dicho esto ¿Por qué todo el mundo conoce
a Berlusconi? ¿Cuál es su legado político?
¿Por qué decimos que ha sido revolucionario
en el mundo empresarial? Hoy vamos a responder
a estas preguntas, pero antes… vamos a ver
un poco de historia.
[Lo primero de todo, y más importante, es
la seguridad en la red. Con Surfshark, tu
actividad online está protegida como si fuera
Fort Knox: cifrada y a salvo de ojos curiosos
que quieran meter mano a tus datos. Además,
con CleanWeb, te despides de los anuncios
y el malware. ¿Y tus emails? Con Surfshark
Alert te enteras al instante si alguien ha
intentado filtrar tu información.
Pero, ¡un momento, hay más! Surfshark es
la primera VPN comercial que tiene servidores
en más de un centenar de países. Imagínate,
es como tener un pasaporte global a un solo
click: puedes acceder a cualquier contenido
bloqueado por ubicación.
Y si te preocupa tener que elegir en qué
dispositivo usarlo, tranquilo. Con la misma
cuenta, puedes proteger todos tus dispositivos,
ya sea tu móvil, tu tablet, la tele o el
ordenador.
Y un pequeño secreto entre tú y yo: puedes
compartir la cuenta con tus colegas. Así,
entre todos, cada uno paga unos céntimos
al mes.
Además por ser parte de la comunidad VisualPolitik
podrás disfrutar de 3 meses extra totalmente
gratis usando el código “POLITIK”.
Y dicho esto, ¡continuemos con nuestro video
de hoy!]
La primera diferencia entre Berlusconi y Donald
Trump es el nacimiento.
Mientras que Trump nació en una familia que
ya era inmensamente rica, Berlusconi nació
en una familia de clase media en Milán. Padres
normales, educación normal y vida normal.
Sin embargo, Berlusconi tenía algo especial:
le fascinaba el espectáculo y era el mejor
comercial que te puedes encontrar. Vamos,
que sería capaz de venderme un peine hasta
a mí.
De hecho, los inicios de Berlusconi fueron…
¡Como cantante! Habéis oído bien. Berlusconi
empezó su carrera como un crooner que amenizaba
fiestas en cruceros y cosas por el estilo.
Por supuesto, aquí también comenzó su fama
como rompecorazones, pero, como hemos dicho…
No vamos a centrarnos en la vida sexual de
nadie porque ¡Somos un canal serio!
El caso es que amenizando las noches milanesas,
Berlusconi hizo los contactos para comenzar
su primer gran proyecto empresarial: MILANO
DUE. Una megapromoción de 4000 viviendas
que fue todo un éxito económico ¡Pero no
os equivoquéis! Lo que a Berlusconi le interesaba
realmente no era el mercado inmobiliario sino…
¡Los medios! De hecho, la tesis doctoral
de Berlusconi versa precisamente sobre el
negocio de la publicidad en los medios de
comunicación -por cierto, tesis con la que
obtuvo una summa cum laude… ¡Vamos, que
de tonto no tenía un pelo!
De hecho, en estos primeros años de su carrera
tenemos que reconocer una cosa: fue todo un
visionario ¿Por qué? Ahora mismo lo vamos
a ver.
T1(EL PADRINO… DE LA TV PRIVADA)
Si veis este vídeo desde EE. UU. os vais
a sorprender, pero… hubo un momento donde
las TVs privadas estaban prohibidas en buena
parte de Europa Y no, ¡no hablamos de la
Europa del Este!
En los años 70, la televisión en Italia
- y en otros países como España - era un
monopolio público. Es decir, si tú encendías
la TV solo tenías los canales de la RAI,
es decir, la corporación de televisión pública
italiana.
Para que os hagáis una idea, en 1973, el
Gobierno Italiano emitió un decreto que prohibía
cualquier intento de montar una televisión
privada.
De hecho, no solo tenían el monopolio de
la televisión sino también el de la PUBLICIDAD
en televisión. Y, creedme, eso era un negocio
muy pero que muy lucrativo. Berlusconi era
perfectamente consciente de esto y, por eso,
su objetivo era acabar con este monopolio
para tener su propia televisión nacional.
La pregunta es ¿Cómo lo hizo? Pues atentos,
porque esta historia es digna de… ¡Un vídeo
de VisualPolitik! La primera pregunta que
tenemos que hacernos es ¿Por qué la TV era
un monopolio? Pues por el espectro radioeléctrico.
(Por aquella época no existía la televisión
digital ni mucho menos internet. La televisión
se emitía por radiofrecuencia y el espectro
radioeléctrico es limitado. Dicho de otra
forma: no hay frecuencias infinitas para todo
aquel que quiera emitir por TV. Sin embargo…
por esos años surgió una nueva tecnología
para emitir televisión.
La televisión por cable ofrecía espacio
suficiente para emitir múltiples canales
de televisión ¿El problema? No todas las
casas en Italia estaban preparadas para recibirla…
¡Salvo las viviendas de Milano DUE!)
Exacto: Berlusconi se encargó de que su promoción
de 4000 viviendas tuviera televisión por
cable. Después de una larga batalla legal,
el Tribunal Constitucional italiano permitió
la creación de televisiones privadas que
emitieran por cable… siempre y cuando lo
hicieran únicamente a nivel local.
Pues bien, Berlusconi tenía a 4000 hogares
que podían convertirse en espectadores de
su propia televisión. Así es como nació
TELEMILANO. Una televisión que ni siquiera
era local… ¡Era una televisión de barrio!
Por supuesto que TeleMilano no era la única
televisión local que emitía por cable, pero
si era una de las más populares porque…
¡Tenía a 4000 espectadores cautivos!
Pero esperad porque esto es solo el principio.
2 años más tarde, en 1976, el Constitucional
volvió a pronunciarse sobre el tema de las
TVs. Esta vez permitieron que las TVs privadas
pudieran emitir por radiofrecuencia SIEMPRE
y cuando fueran simplemente locales. Es decir,
podías tener una TV en Milan, Torino o Roma…
pero no una tele que emitiera a nivel nacional
¿Y qué creéis que hizo Berlusconi en este
momento?
Pues el bueno de Silvio se dedicó a comprar
todas las Teles locales de todas las regiones
de Italia. En pocos años, se hizo con Roma
TV, Video Veneto, TeleTorino… básicamente,
consiguió hacerse con todas las TVs privadas
del país ¿Siguiente paso? Unirlas en el
primer grupo de comunicación de Italia. En
1981, todas estas televisiones locales cambiaron
sus logos por el de CANAL 5.
(Y así es como Berlusconi consiguió lo que
parecía imposible: acabar con un monopolio
público. Ahora podía competir cara a cara
con el imperio de la RAI. Gracias a tener
una red nacional de TVs, Canal 5 podía fichar
a los comunicadores más populares de la TV
pública. Así es como el famoso MIKE BUONGIORNO
se fue de la corporación pública a la nueva
y flamante televisión privada. La estrategia
no podía ser más agresiva. Berlusconi quería
comerse el mercado y, para eso, no reparó
en gastos. Compró las series más populares
de Estados Unidos y hasta introdujo el anime
japonés en los hogares italianos. Para que
os hagáis una idea, sólo entre 1980 y 1981,
Canal 5 pasó de facturar 13.000 millones
de liras a más de 75.000. Para el año 1987,
la tele de Berlusconi ya tenía el 48% de
la cuota de pantalla de todo el país.)
Por si no estáis pasmados todavía, recordad
que tan solo 15 años antes, las televisiones
privadas en Italia ni siquiera estaban permitidas
por la ley. Y esto, es un mérito que le tenemos
que reconocer a Berlusconi. Pero si pensabais
que su carrera empresarial se queda aquí,
estáis muy equivocados: después de conquistar
Italia, Silvio se lanzó a conquistar Europa
¡Y vaya si lo hizo! Así es como nació el
GRUPO MEDIASET, que todavía hoy es uno de
los grupos de comunicación más grandes de
Europa.
Básicamente, este hombre se dedicó a comprar
acciones de muchas de las televisiones privadas
que empezaban a surgir en otros países de
su entorno. Y aquí es donde llegamos a…
¡España! Hasta el año 1989, la televisión
privada también estaba prohibida en España.
Pero en los años 90, el Gobierno acabó con
el monopolio público. Y ahí estaba Silvio,
también conocido como “il Cabaglieri”,
listo para hacerse con TELE 5. De nuevo, si
sois españoles y habéis vivido los años
90, no hace falta que os explique lo que supuso
Tele5 en los medios de comunicación. Habrá
quién diga que este fue el inicio de la telebasura
y el sensacionalismo. Pero nadie puede negar
que fue un antes y un después en el modo
en el que se entendía ese medio.
Y aquí llegamos a la parte más oscura del
carrerón empresarial de Berlusconi: la deuda.
No const ruyes semejante imperio mediático
en poco más de 10 años sin pedir dinero
prestado a medio mundo.
Para el año 1994, Finininvest, que es el
brazo financiero del imperio de Silvio, era
la segunda empresa más endeudada de toda
Italia. Y, en ese momento… ¿Qué creéis
que hizo? ¿Cuál es el siguiente paso cuando
te has convertido en el amo y señor de los
medios? Pues… recoger tus cosas ¡Y marcharte
de la empresa! ¡Habéis oído bien! En 1994,
Berlusconi dejó todos sus puestos de mando.
Eso sí, mantuvo todas las acciones de su
imperio. Quedaos con este dato porque es importante
para la siguiente fase de la historia. Porque…
¿A dónde fue Berlusconi? Pues ahora mismo
lo vamos a ver.
T2( LA CONQUISTA POLÍTICA)
¡La política italiana es una auténtica
locura! Da igual cuando escuches esto… vale
para cualquier época de la historia. En este
país, los primeros ministros duran de media
2.5 años. Si estudiáis la política italiana
vais a encontrar: conspiraciones llevadas
a cabo por logias secretas, terrorismo de
estado y, por supuesto, mafias de todos los
colores. Solo había una cosa constante: la
DEMOCRACIA CRISTIANA. Hablamos de un partido
político de centro-derecha que dominó el
país durante toda la Guerra Fría.
Sin embargo… en 1994, la Democracia Cristiana
se disolvió por una espiral de escándalos
de corrupción dignos de una república bananera.
La derecha estaba huérfana… y la izquierda
no convencía a los votantes. Pero… allí
donde hay gente dispuesta a comprar, hay alguien
dispuesto a vender ¿Y quién sabía vender
mejor que nadie? ¡Exacto! Silvio Berlusconi.
Durante los años 80, había apoyado públicamente
al Partido Socialista. Pero ahora sabía que,
si quería ganar elecciones, tenía que cambiar
de bando. Y así es como creó su propio partido
de centro-derecha. Aunque… bueno, realmente
podríamos decir que era un partido sin ideología.
Básicamente, el proceso fue el siguiente
¿Qué les gusta a los italianos más que
la pizza y las mujeres? ¡El futbol! ¿Y qué
gritan los italianos cuando apoyan a su selección
nacional? ¡¡¡FORZA ITALIA!!! ¡Fenomenal!
Pues ya tenemos nombre del partido ¿Ideología?
Pues… estamos a favor de lo bueno y en contra
de lo malo ¿Quién no va a votar a un partido
así? Así es como, en 1994, año del Mundial
de Fútbol, Berlusconi creó Forza Italia.
Creo que no hace falta que os diga que ese
mismo año Berlusconi ganó las elecciones.
Y diréis ¿Por qué? Tres razones: primera,
tenía el control de la televisión más grande
del país, segunda… el resto de partidos
estaban matándose en disputas internas y
tercera, estamos hablando de una de las personalidades
más carismáticas que se han conocido.
Y así es como empezó la carrera política
más impresionante de la historia de Italia
¡Ojo! Esto no significa que Silvio haya ganado
siempre las elecciones. Recordad que la política
italiana es un caos… ¡Incluso para él!
Ha sido primer ministro en distintos periodos
interrumpidos.
Ahora bien, podemos decir que Berlusconi ha
sido el político que más años ha gobernado
Italia. Y también podemos decir que ha sido
el primer ministro con más poder ¿Por qué?
Porque no solo controlaba la política sino
también los medios.
Para que os hagáis una idea, según estimaciones
de The Economist, en 2001, llegó a controlar
el 91% de la cuota de pantalla de las TVs
italianas. Pensadlo así: era el dueño de
Canal 5 y, a la vez, dominaba la televisión
pública. Conclusión: el hombre que acabó
con el monopolio de la TV en los 80 terminó
construyendo otro monopolio.
(Y aquí es donde llegamos a la parte más
oscura de su vida. Porque si el poder corrompe,
el poder absoluto corrompe absolutamente.
Y Berlusconi convirtió el parlamento en su
patio trasero. Simple y llanamente aprobó
leyes hechas a su medida. Por ejemplo, en
2004, Italia aprobó una ley para dar ayudas
para la compra de decodificadores de TV digital
¿Quién tenía la principal empresa que vendía
estos aparatos? ¡Exacto! La familia de Berlusconi.
Y este es sólo un ejemplo más de una larguísima
lista: amnistías fiscales, regulaciones financieras…
podemos decir que Silvio cambió Italia para
hacerla a la medida de sus intereses.)
Pero ahora vamos a lo más importante de todo:
la foto general ¿Qué saldo político deja
Berlusconi? Aparte de la corrupción… ¿Ha
sido bueno para los italianos? Pues ahora
mismo lo vamos a ver.
T3(EL PODER POR EL PODER)
La economía italiana está incluso peor que
su clase política… da igual cuando leas
esto. En realidad, Italia tuvo una época
muy buena en los años 80. Es decir, cuando
Berlusconi construyó su imperio empresarial,
el país estaba on fire.
A principios de los años 90, los italianos
eran más ricos que los británicos y estaban
cerca de alcanzar a los alemanes. Ahora, sin
embargo, Italia es el enfermo de Europa. Uno
de los pocos países que es ahora más pobre
que hace 20 años. Y diréis ¿Por qué? Tenemos
un par de vídeos donde lo explicamos en detalles:
uno de VisualPolitik y otro de VisualEconomik.
Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
Pero os hago un breve resumen. Italia arrastra
problemas sistémicos que hacen que sea casi
imposible que funcione. Tiene un estado enorme
y totalmente ineficiente, con más de 3 millones
de funcionarios y muchísimo gasto público
¡Pero eso no es todo! Una de las grandes
debilidades de Italia es la burocracia más
absurda que os podáis imaginar. Por ejemplo,
casi todas las profesiones están colegiadas.
Eso significa que si quieres trabajar como
periodista o informático, necesitas una licencia.
Y conseguir esa licencia es un proceso que
parece de otra época.
Como curiosidad, os contaré que aquí, en
VisualPolitik, estuvimos trabajando durante
un tiempo con una guionista italiana. Esa
guionista quería conseguir la licencia de
periodista. Para eso, tenía que demostrar
experiencia en medios. Pero, por lo visto,
trabajar en un canal de YouTube no es experiencia
en medios. Según la burocracia italiana,
un canal de YouTube con millones de seguidores
no cuenta como un medio de comunicación ¿Por
qué? Porque… razones.
Pues bien, con todos estos problemas, la Italia
de los años 80 crecía gracias a una cosa:
eran adictos a la devaluación.
Italia devaluaba su divisa para que sus productos
fueran más baratos en el mercado internacional.
Durante los 80 y 90, el “Made in Italy”
arrasaba en Europa ¿Problema? En la década
de los 2000, China entró en la Organización
Mundial del Comercio e Italia entró en el
euro. Conclusión: no podían competir con
los precios aún más baratos de las empresas
chinas… y tampoco podían devaluar su divisa
¿Conclusión? Una larga crisis de la que
aún no han salido.
(En este momento, Italia es el 7º país del
mundo en deuda en relación con el PIB y el
5º en deuda per cápita. Y de hecho, hoy
en día, Italia es uno de los mayores dolores
de cabeza de toda Europa. Y en cierto modo
buena parte de eso se debe a lo que hizo,
o más bien NO hizo Berlusconi pese a tener
más poder que casi ningún otro político.)
Y diréis ¿Qué ha hecho Berlusconi en los
últimos años? Pues lo cierto es que nunca
ha abandonado la política.
Sin embargo, apenas podemos destacar ninguna
posición política interesante… salvo esta.
(Silvio Berlusconi: el Ex primer ministro
defiende la guerra rusa a las puertas de las
elecciones italianas. BBC)
¡Exacto! Berlusconi ha estado apoyando a
Rusia en la guerra de Ucrania. Y diréis ¿Por
qué? Pues su argumentación se basaba en
que… Conocía personalmente a Vladimir Putin
y eran muy buenos amigos. En este caso, parece
que la vida privada de Berlusconi SÍ afecta
a sus posiciones políticas… o eso se desprende
de fotos como esta.
¿Conclusión? Nadie puede negar que Berlusconi
fue un auténtico genio: un hombre hecho a
sí mismo. Consiguió tener más poder que
casi ningún otro hombre en la historia: juntó
en una misma persona el poder económico,
político y mediático. Sin embargo, utilizó
todo ese poder de una forma, cuanto menos,
mediocre. Pero ahora la pregunta es para vosotros:
¿Llegaremos a ver a un nuevo líder que aglutine
tanto poder como Berlusconi? ¿Hay otros líderes
internacionales que podamos comparar con il
Cavaglieri? Y… ¿Os gustaría llegar a los
80 y tantos años con tantísima energía
como Silvio? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta
en los comentarios. Como siempre, no olvidéis
que aquí, en VisualPolitik, sacamos vídeos
nuevos todas las semanas así que suscribíos
a este canal y dadle a la campanita para no
perderos ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones.
Si os ha gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE
y nos vemos en el próximo. Un saludo y hasta
pronto.